I'm excited I'll have a beverage a crisp
beverage I'm thirsty today we are
swapping drinks Korean Americans
unfortunately we're not doing alcoholic
drinks I know right yeah I really get
drunk at work have you oh wow
but I forget when I drank and you also
grew up with also Korean and American
drinks right I've had like a couple of
drinks left I see and like everybody had
stuff like that all right all right so
banana milk I grew up in Korea like when
I was younger and then I go to sauna
my grandma would take me up and sitting
like hot water for like five minutes it
gets frickin hot yeah and then you come
out and you drink this cold banana milk
and it just changes your life forever
there's definitely like a 40 and thing
going on here if you're butt naked and
then you're like oh I'm gonna have mana
I mean you have a treat today it is a
yoo-hoo now yoo-hoo
one might say it is choco milk but that
is incorrect it is a chocolate drink so
it's not milk
that's good it's good yeah it could use
some like wrong maybe not when you're
like in a sauna and you're like sweating
it out I mean you're like it's a one-way
ticket to popping out and the sauna oh
my gosh it tastes like you know how like
the residue of cereal when you pour milk
and cereal and any of that flavor
if the cereal was banana flavored and
you pour the milk over it that's what it
tastes like
[Music]
tastes like chocolate milk
do you drink milk when you're growing up
no I didn't because I'm super lactose
it's supposed to make you taller and
that's what oh yeah like your bones are
really strong and I'm like I'd rather
this have a grilled cheese
oh saying yeah about that yeah what does
it taste like then just chocolate eggs
just a chocolate water I know that
doesn't sound so appetizing but it's
like the best version of chocolate water
yeah yeah your finest oh no I'm going
with this one for sure
this is my choice banana milk
yeah I'm gonna go up an animal it's like
topical and fun plus you get to be naked
in a song okay
so milk is is popular recently it's a
carbonated drink it's made from what
they uh to some set up it's kind of like
cream spray basically you can say it's a
carbonated milk
it's a soda it's a soda this is a yogurt
soju without the alcohol content yeah so
it's like so I have here Capri Sun this
is like the elementary school special oh
and you get it I your lunchable and you
get to snap snap you just like nothing
more refreshing and satisfying you feel
on this this hole right here you could
set it here this is the backup area plan
B
[Music]
smells like maybe they fix this
Plan B with exhales okay you try fresh
[Music]
it's hard to explain the flavor because
it doesn't really taste like milk or
yogurt like this tastes like a soda have
you ever had an egg cream no that
doesn't it's like an East Coast thing
there's no egg in it but it's like
chocolate cream and then salts are
delicious it kind of tastes like this
except this is like lemon instead of
chocolate it's sort of like a very thin
milk shape that's a great explanation
yeah it's delicious well I'm gonna go
for the tropical punch I've actually
only like the Pacific cooler ones but
cool CBJ oh I think this is my favorite
flavor oh let's bring back good memories
in Pokemon like oh come on yeah I like
this
oh you just pounded that what you got
there do you guys thank you time
lemonade it's kind of similar to what
you were talking about earlier it's like
a powder but you take like a tablespoon
and then you mix it and your cup and
then you got like fresh lemonade oh I've
never seen that in my life
all right next we have shake a shake it
is carefully made traditional beverage
it's a rice sweet dessert drink oh
that's a good comparison but without
that like cinnamon kick to it and
basically when you pour those rice bits
in it because they drain the water from
the rice is it like a palate cleanser or
look interesting okay that's good for
digestion as well all right I don't have
a spoon with me because I'm ill prepared
this is the government resources
available to us I'm just the relative
that's a beautiful yellow right here
it's like my favorite yellow that's a
beautifully colored yellow I can look at
this yellow all day oh it does look like
a legit lemonade okay so let's swap okay
you see that right yes I do I love rice
so and I love for Chavez so I'm
intrigued it looks like there's popcorn
kernels on it it's rice and it's also a
very off-putting color yeah I'm not
gonna lie it's so pure this color of
angels soul or the color appears
oh you like it I really like it it
tastes nothing like rice to me really
it's sweet like a honey flavor almost
can I be honest this is not my favorite
thing I've had so far I like the milky
better this is great it's definitely not
too sour and then it's not sweet so it's
like it right in the middle for me and
scream I'm just gonna say I like the
lemonade better for this one this is the
first time that I think I like the
American Beverage butter
yeah I've really liked the cream on so
far but for this you can't beat it
okay so for cardioid is actually not
Korean drinks this is Japanese drink but
is extremely popular and influenced by a
lot of Koreans so people think this is
Korean drinks but it's actually not
basically it's a sports energy drink
that's sport players take after they
play sports so iterate it is kind of
like Gatorade without flavor they had I
on supply to recharge you so kind of
like oh I believe you oh I got you the
classic other fruit punch hi-c it packs
a punch it tastes like a generic fruit
flavor and it's great I love that on
ours you know it says what it is
hi-c flash and fruit punch this one
sweat I bet this is great for hangovers
[Music]
it just sounds like really smart like oh
yeah we're a charger oh yeah I like both
of these it almost tastes the same as
the briefs on actually it tastes like
the color red which is supposed to be
cherry or strawberry but what's
interesting is is no there's no cherry
on this line so it's kind of confusion
okay this has to be my ultimate go-to
Korean drink it's called sock sock
basically
a drink great great balls yes
and then you just drink in you taste all
these great balls inside your mouth and
like you chew it and then it explodes
here let me show it to you this creeps
coming out we are those like peeled
grapes they look like real grace yours
is so it's like on the jinyo Girt it's a
legit yoghurt you can drink okay answers
please
it's almost like when you would a
dentist as a kid yes huh yeah after
things you should definitely try this in
the cup and then in the case okay so
it's like a multi-sensory experience
mm-hmm well that is good it's good like
grape juice and they call it sack sack
I'm not mature enough to be jerking
Korean beverages no they don't know a
lot of people just like a pc cafe mm-hmm
lot of Korean students go to a pc cafe
after school that they would like get a
pen of this and registry it disappear
water playing games um by to pick one I
think I'd pick this as an adult but I
think I'd pick this as a kid same here
dogs I think most of the American drinks
I had was very fruity pug sheep we like
our fruit flavors for yes what about you
what is your thoughts I thought it was
interesting that the predominant
American flavor was fruit punch flavor
and the predominate Korean flavor is
more like creamy theory ish but not
quite those Korean beverages were
delicious
I love the milky want and I love sack
sack that's definitely my favorite sack
sack is my favorite and I kept priest
son
Capri something so good I think we need
to go to a Korean spa and drink some
socks yes I'm doing you a comment yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you